there were there were two questions in
the facebook group uh about
uh optimizing biomechanics from gavin
chester and ross quigley
so gavin asked how important is quote
unquote optimizing biomechanics for
hypertrophy for example adjusting line
of resistance with the direction of the
muscle fibers etc
we're also chimed in i second this i see
a lot of instagram accounts that go into
detail on both lines of resistance
strength slash resistance curves active
range of motion for a given muscle etc
and basically like how important is that
stuff do you need to be concerned about
it um
and uh yeah so
my perspective is that
it's hard it's hard to know so so this
is a
uh partially scientific answer and
partially just
my opinion and vibes based answer
and the reason it's hard to give a
fully scientific answer to this
is that uh a lot of the ideas that that
people are putting forth are
not directly tested so like you know for
example if you say a
particular type of way of doing cable
rows is going to build your rhomboids
way more than some standard way of doing
maybe like uh
inclined bench dumbbell rows like
your your
it's your prerogative to make that claim
uh but that hasn't been researched so
you know could be correct could be
incorrect um but it's hard to
objectively say
so
you know we we are
mostly in the realm of opinion and
conjecture here uh but my perspective is
that it's probably a matter of degree
um and for example the principle itself
of of different exercises or different
variations of exercises
maybe being more or less effective for
hypertrophy in general or hypertrophy of
a particular region of a muscle
that general idea does have some
scientific support so again not support
for specific individual exercises but
just kind of the concept itself so for
example there's
there's one study showing that incline
bench builds the upper pecs better than
flat bench we've talked about that on
the podcast before i'm a little bit
skeptical of that study but just noting
that that it exists um
there's a recent study showing that knee
extensions build the rectus femoris way
better than
like squats do so
you know you can't necessarily assume
that all quad exercises will build all
heads of the quads equally
there's a study showing that bench press
and triceps build like different heads
or uh bench press and tricep extensions
build different heads of the triceps so
for example
binge press seem to be really good for
specifically building the lateral head
of the tricep
whereas the long head of the tricep was
grown a lot more effectively with like
skull crushers
so there's there's direct evidence on
that
and then just regional muscle activation
in response to different exercises and
uh regional muscle hypertrophy are are
pretty well established phenomena at
this point so just kind of on a baseline
level there is
there is reason to believe
that um
you know attempting to to quote-unquote
optimize exercises for a particular like
to target particular muscles um might
have some merit even if there's not
direct evidence for
the specific exercises or exercise
variations being discussed
and there's also some research showing
that relatively small quote unquote
optimizations can have a notable effect
on hypertrophy so it's not just a matter
of say bench press versus tricep
extensions for different heads of the
triceps even relatively small variations
of the same general exercise may be more
or less effective so there was a study
by
mayo
i believe from this past year looking at
hypertrophy of the hamstrings following
seated or lying hamstring curls finding
that seated hamstring curls were quite a
bit more effective for hypertrophy
probably because they
they were training the hamstrings at a
longer muscle length so if you're seated
you're in some hip flexion that
lengthens the hamstrings might make
seated leg curls a little bit more
effective for hamstring growth than
lying leg curl so there there even is
some evidence
that uh
relatively small quote unquote
optimizations like that could be
effective
um
personally
i i do think that
the most important factors uh are just
um range of motion so for example can
you
load the target muscle at relatively
long muscle lengths like near the end of
its range of motion
and also just whether the exercise
you're doing um is likely to be limited
by the muscle you're the most interested
in so
you know for example um
take dumbbell bench versus bench press
some people's bench press performance
might be limited by their triceps or by
their shoulders and for them maybe the
bench press might not be the most
effective
uh
pec builder but
with dumbbell press for example for
virtually everyone that's going to be
limited by their pecs so
you know that would probably tend to
make it uh an effective pec exercise for
most people um so i think those are the
two biggest factors just range of motion
and whether or not the target muscle is
going to be the limiting muscle for
uh the exercise being performed and the
other caveat i'd throw in is that i
think for biarticular muscles there's
some decent evidence to suggest that
single joint exercises tend to be more
effective than multi-joint exercises so
i mentioned tricep extensions versus
bench press for
growth of the long head of the triceps
tricep extensions were more effective
long head of the tricep is a multi-joint
muscle
and same thing with knee extensions for
rectus femoris growth again
the rectus femoris is a biarticular
muscle single joint exercise seemed to
be better
so you know i think that those are
the main factors to keep in mind whether
or not
optimizations passed to that point make
much of a difference
i'm kind of agnostic on
um
and uh i i think that
i i think that in general a way to
approach it
is
just kind of to ask yourself whether you
[Music]
need something fresh for for a
particular muscle or not so
you know for example if you've got
pretty big pecs and you feel
most kind of standard pec exercises in
your pecs they feel pretty pumped pretty
fatigued after you do some pec training
i don't think you need to go out seeking
crazy new pec exercises like you
certainly could just if you
want something new to do for novelty's
sake but i personally don't think it's
going to affect your your results all
that much however if there is a
particular muscle group where
like just the the standard go-to
exercises don't really seem to be doing
it for you so i i think like lats are a
pretty common one a lot of people don't
feel their lats as much as they would
like to if they're if they were doing uh
pull-ups pull-downs pull-overs just kind
of like standard lat exercises uh and
and maybe they have
relatively poor lat development compared
to the rest of their physique
if you come across someone on instagram
or some other platform saying like here
are some crazy new lat exercises that
that will really blow up your lats and
help you feel your lats contract and
doing what you want them to uh if pull
downs aren't getting the job done for
you
i mean my perspective is it it doesn't
hurt to give it a shot
you know if what you're current
currently doing isn't working uh
at minimum it doesn't hurt to try out a
new idea i do think that a lot of the
kind of
i think that a lot of the reasoning
underpinning a lot of the exercises be
that that might be recommended kind of
under the umbrella or for the purpose of
like quote unquote optimizing exercise
technique i i do think that
the the reasoning
some might be a little bit flimsy at
times and it kind of reminds me a little
bit of like keto content
so
they they both kind of go with like
here's a plausible sounding mechanism i
tried this thing and it seemed to work
for me
and therefore we can generalize it and
and it's a good thing for everyone so in
the case of keto like
hey
like insulin is this thing and like oh
that's that seems scary and like i tried
a low carb diet
help me control my appetite and lose
weight therefore like low carb keto is
the best everyone should do it and i i
get kind of the same vibe
from the kind of like galaxy brain like
exercise variation stuff like oh man if
you like do do rows on this exact
machine in this exact way like it
technically lines up with like the
the line of pull for this region of your
lats a little bit better and like i
tried it and i got i got a pretty good
pump off of it so like
everyone should do it this way this is
this is way better than the typical way
of doing this exercise
i don't know to to me it seems like it
it seems like some of that content makes
some jumps that are somewhat
unjustifiable
and at minimum
makes claims with more
with a with a higher level of confidence
than is fully justifiable like
you know
here's a plausible mechanism and it
seemed to feel good for me
uh
i i don't think is enough evidence to
therefore
recommend it as a generally superior
thing for everyone um
so yeah i
some of it leaves a bad taste in my
mouth but i i think i have a
um
i think i have a generally
sympathetic perspective to it um like i
said i think
most of the time the old standards get
the job done for most people but i also
think it it doesn't hurt to have more
tools in the toolbox if there are some
muscle groups that say
just just aren't aren't going well for
you like the stand the the old classic
exercises don't really seem to be doing
what you want them to do or if you're a
coach and you train clients and like you
know
for a particular client they just for
whatever reason
feel
uh like rdls in their glutes and they
feel leg curls in their [ __ ] calves
because your gastroc is also
technically a knee flexor and like man
this client just can't grow their
hamstrings like what do i do you know i
don't think it hurts to consume some of
that content because if someone has a
galaxy brain idea for a novel hamstring
exercise doesn't hurt to know it exists
to try it out with a client who might be
struggling to feel their hamstrings
working with with kind of classic
hamstring exercises so i'm sympathetic
to it overall but i do think a lot of
that content um
kind of like
overstates what
the the reasoning and evidence that
backs it up but
like i said i i would say i'm
vaguely sympathetic towards it
have you come across any great exercises
to really light up your pop lydias
because i could use some of those if you
have any i have not although i will say
uh here here's kind of a
weird looking but
uh like
galaxy brain like quote unquote like
optimized version of an exercise that i
thought looked ridiculous um before i
tried it and now absolutely love uh and
also this uh this exercise comes from
like one of only three t-nation articles
that i regularly share with people so uh
john meadows
had a really good t-nation article back
in the day i maybe it may have been like
2011 2012 like it was
it was quite a bit in the past but it
was on shoulder training
and uh one of the things i had always
noticed is like
i never felt my rear delts doing
anything like if i just did kind of like
normal rear delt raises
they'd get they'd get a little bit of a
pump but like i'd mostly feel it in my
rhomboids and mid traps
um
and i didn't have particularly good rear
delt growth which was actually a problem
for me as a power lifter because i had
no shelf for low bar squatting uh and
like i wanted i wanted to try low bar
high bar seemed to be fine but i had
zero rear delt development so uh like i
could do singles for low bar squats but
if i tried to do reps the bar would
start sliding uh and so i come i come
across this t nation article uh by by
john meadows who i liked and respected
uh seemed seemed to be putting out good
content and so uh the rear delt exercise
he recommended
was you basically just take
way heavier dumbbells than you could
possibly do full range of motion with
and you're basically face down on a
bench and doing like super partial range
of motion rear delt raises
um
and you know you're you're intentionally
trying to relax your scapula and not
like retract on every rep and so you're
just doing like little swings that
you're only using your rear delts for uh
and then you're also trying to like make
sure the dumbbells don't hit at the
bottom so like there is still some
eccentric component where you're using
your rear delts to decelerate the
dumbbells so they don't claim together
at the bottom of every rep
and i gotta say man i love them they're
great that's the only rear delt exercise
that really blows up my rear delts they
they're [ __ ] toasted at the end
they're the only things that make my
rear delts sore and i got some some very
solid rear delt growth out of them uh
they finally gave me that shelf to where
i could uh
rest the bar pretty comfortably for low
bar squats so yeah i'm
i'm sympathetic to the idea i just think
that that sometimes people over play
their hands um
and
you know i see it less personally i see
it less of like here are more optimized
versions of exercises that are going to
work way better for people i see it more
of like
i had a creative idea for how you could
target this muscle and if you struggle
to target this muscle uh here here's an
idea to try out like that that's how i
personally uh
interact with with content like that
um
so yeah you can you can view it however
you please